j'accueille marilyn manson
ah ah
bonsoir
italie de troc tout à l'heure
j'étais même pas encore arrivé bonsoir
marilyn donc vous appelez marilyn comme
monroe et manson comme charles manson ça
vous est venu comment cette idée
d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur en série
satanistes avec le prénom d'une icône
glamour de l'amérique
je voulais être la meilleure
représentation possible de l'amérique
votre surnom ses entés christ superstar
cela c'est bien que vous en pensez hervé
un antéchrist superstar
c'était non
la relève est assurée et marilyn manson
est une star donc du shock rock ce qu'on
peut appeler le shock rock alors dans la
tradition de badis toons avec sympathy
for the devil
ensuite il est black sabbath avec ozzy
osbourne alice cooper les sexpistols je
suis un artiste je suis l'antéchrist
chantait johnny rotten alors on est très
contents de vous avoir ce soir parce que
vous êtes une star mondiale marilyn les
prochaines album s'appelle the golden
age of grotesque l'âge d'or du grotesque
et le premier single est déjà sorti et
il s'appelle m'obstine juste il rien
email qui vient de tomber beaucoup de
gens règlent leur téléviseur tout ça est
normal
peut-être que les gens croient qu'ils
regardent deux chaînes à la fois une
ceinture et maître capello une chaîne
humaine
pas du tout c'est la même chaîne c'est
france 2 vient donc sortie de votre
album ottomane album et puis l'autre
raison de votre présence ici c'est le
succès mondial du documentaire de
michael moore qui s'appelle bowling for
columbine dont qui a été évidemment pris
mais un peu partout au ceasar's oscars
qui consacrait aux armes à feu aux usa
alors qu'hollande bein c'est une
université du michigan ou deux élèves
avaient ouvert le feu sur des camarades
et on s'était aperçu après que c'était
des des fans de vous voilà donc ces deux
raisons de on en parlera plus tard deux
raisons nous avoir ce soir mais on va
commencer par le début manson vous êtes
né le 5 janvier 69 et votre vrai nom
c'est brian hugh warner
votre père était un ancien mécanicien
d'hélicoptère au vietnam
si
je me trompe jamais moi un oiseau ce
week-end monde il gérait une magasin de
meubles et
les seuls moments d'intimité de votre
père avec vous c'était quand ils vous
emmener au stand de tir pour vous
apprendre à tirer c'était un vrai moment
d'intimité avec lui et puis aussi il
vous emmener au concert de kiss un bar
très douces en bon père abel justement
un maquillage qui s'est mal un concert
dans cette tenue mon papa était
découlent
ça c'est votre papa votre maman celle
inverse elle était très possessive
traître est étouffante comme ça et quand
vous êtes petit marilyn manson vous
passez beaucoup de temps chez vos
grands-parents et vous découvrez la
sexualité dans la cave de votre grand
père voilà alors dans la cave du
grand-père à ça te plait ça james ah la
la alors dans la cave du grand-père de
marilyn y avait quoi maître capello dans
la cave du grand père jack matin il y
avait des nuages qui avait irrité
lingerie féminine il y avait des
godemichés enduits de vaseline les
godemichés
et puis aussi des photos au fil à
aillas est assez juste mais c'est très
drôle de grand père
avec notamment
quand j'étais gamin mon grand-père me
paraissait le monstrueux mais en
grandissant je me suis rendu compte que
mon grand-père était bon je suis comme
lui est pas si mal que ça
que je n'aime pas trop les animaux dans
les faits la zoophilie ce qui n'a pas
tiré un cheval lancé
moi je t'ai la peur donc
j'aime voir son père alors donc vous
aider à l'école est l'héritage
christians cool hein et là évidemment
aux mises à part dont puisqu'il a aussi
agi dans ce sens que j'aime en faire un
ami de capello merci même plus donc
voila vous allez dans cette école donc
pour vous inculque des valeurs fondées
sur l'antéchrist et sur l'apocalypse
alors évidemment ça astuces assassa
travail dans votre tête vous essayez de
vous adapter à l'école vous essayez de
vous adapter et un jour vous leur
apportez
une photo c'est des nuages dans le ciel
qui représente un ange et lui pense
qu'ils pensent là un vous pensez leur
faire plaisir
c'était ma grand mère
ils m'ont dit que c'était un faux et
donc
c'était la seule fois j'essaie de
m'intégrer vraiment dans ce but qu'on
m'a dit que tout ça c'était du bidon
mais j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de croire
ou des c3 à ce que me racontait est
alors au lieu de vivre dans la peur
d'avoir des cauchemars j'ai décidé de
devenir ce dont j'avais peur juste mais
voilà alors là c'est la révolte dès
l'âge de 12 ans vous vous révoltez vous
êtes attiré par tout ce qui est interdit
vous êtes à l'époque vous est maigre
vous êtes couvert de boutons vous êtes
toujours tout seul enfin vous avez une
adolescence ça c'est assez terrible non
moi je me sentais invisible et
transparence c'était pas tous été
rejetés j'étais vraiment invisible on ne
me voyait pas et ça ne l'est qu'à
travers la musique ou l'écriture quand
j'étais gamin je me suis dit je serai
artistes les écrivains je pensais que
j'allais chanter parce que je ne savais
pas chanter mais bon
et c'est comme ça que j'ai trouvé ma
propre voie je crée mon monde et alors
là en compagnie d'un certain john kroell
et de son grand frère au lycée vous
commencé à vous intéresser aux sciences
occultes
qu une bonne conscience
dans un football un tube non non mais
c'est bien parce que comme ça ça
cautionne et c'est une bonne idée d'en
c'est le service public service public
sont bien donc vous intéresser avec ce
dénommé john cromwell aux sciences
occultes aux doctrines satanique 1 c'est
l'époque où vous visiter disneyland eux
sous acide des
ca propose cet épisode rappelle un peu
cet épisode un peu surréaliste et là où
fait de la scène donc c'est le scandale
évidemment vous masturber sur scène un
faux pénis qui éjacule un liquide
d'improbables vous jeter des n'a pas eu
recours à un accessoire de
vous jeter des poulets vivants au public
mais c'est vrai que c'est le public qui
les égorge
[Musique]
oui
alors marilyn au sujet de votre
cinquième album sur le précédent vous
avez déclaré c'est l'histoire d'un
innocent qui veut faire partie d'un
monde qui ne l'acceptent pas il se bat
il découvre sa révolution et finit par
devenir un objet marketing aujourd'hui
vous êtes devenu un objet marketing
ce que je fais je l'exploité et d'en
faire ils ont une marchandise et bien il
yal'affaire donc de colomb aille donc
cette université du michigan où deux
fans ouvrent le feu sur leurs camarades
et les médias américains vous accuse
alors vous répondez on peut pas accuser
shakespeare de pousser les gens au
suicide parce qu'il a écrit roméo et
juliette enfin c'est vrai quand même que
les gens qui ont tiré sur leurs
camarades étaient des fans de marilyn
manson
accès en fait il fallait un coupable
donc on m'a brandi un peu embêtant c'est
cette effigie du coupage et j'ai décidé
de ne pas répondre à tout cela parce que
je ne voulais pas justement donné les
alimenter cette flamme les gamins
voulait justement acquérir une espèce de
célébrités malsaine la mairie fera à
tenait justement ce qu'il recherchait et
je voulais pas y contribuer donc on
associe le nom marilyn manson à cette
horreur et en fait marine manson est
devenu le produit de colombes a été
ironiquement c'est quand même assez
injuste d'être attaqué par vos
promenades de
santé actuel et il n'a pas traduit
vêtements parlement mais en fait tu
venais la finesse
vous dites que cette histoire finalement
permettait d'oublier monica levinsky
parce qu'à l'époque c'était le grand
scandale de monica levinsky on oublie
aussi grâce à ça les bombes balancer sur
le kosovo et vous dites c'est moi qu'on
accuse de provoquer un comportement
violent alors que finalement à la même
époque les états unis bombardé la
yougoslavie
absolue est exactement
celle des seniors au cou en dire autant
de ce qui se passe actuellement c'est à
dire qu'on va continuer à censurer les
mots
les images ou mais où ma musique
en fait il ya un véritable duplicité du
gouvernement et moi mon rôle c'est
justement de mettre cette démarche défi
il faut que moi si l'amérique représente
la démocratie moi je dois représenter la
liberté de création ce n'est pas
quelqu'un comme moi qui aurais personnes
justement pour remettre en cause les
fausses idées nous à moi qui irai que
revient le rôle justement de remettre en
cause certaines politiques certaines
valeurs ce qui ne veut pas dire que je
déteste les jeux l'acceptent parce
qu'elle est mon rôle c'est d'en faire un
pays plus intéressant plus
divertissement en étant beau gosse
d'accord
alors dans le film quand michael moore
vous pose la question et vous dites
qu'est ce que vous diriez au lycée en
colombie et vous répondez je les
écouterai ce que personne ne fait rien
c'est quelque chose que je deviens un
départ avant l'incident de koloma
n'était pas la première fois qu'une
telle tragédie ne se produise c'est pas
moi qui ai inventé la violence n'est pas
non plus les gamins de colobane compte
amender la violence l'oeil du manager à
cette tendance une tradition de
s'autodétruire et ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai toujours évoqué dans ma musique
alors c'est quand même assez curieux
qu'on me montre du doigt parce que tout
ce que je dis tout ce que je chante
c'est un commentaire ce cette triste
réalité et il est vachement saget a
compilé par les nantis
bien merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu